the largest things in the universe are
black holes
in contrast to things like planets or
stars they have no
physical size limit and can literally
grow endlessly
although in reality specific things need
to happen to create different kinds of
black holes from really tiny ones
to the largest single things in the
universe
so how do black holes grow and how large
is the largest of them all
this video will not discuss how black
holes work or how they form
since we've looked at that in detail in
our black hole and neutron star series
you can check them out afterwards for
now we're interested in finding the
largest thing in the universe
let's start really really small
primordial black holes the smallest kind
of black holes may or
may not exist if they do they're
probably the oldest objects in the
universe
older even than atoms they would have
formed just after the big bang
when the universe was so dense with
violent energy that any tiny pocket that
was just slightly more dense than its
neighbors
could produce a black hole the smallest
primordial black hole that could still
be around would be a trillion kilograms
or so
the mass of a big mountain and yet they
would be no bigger than a proton
a primordial black hole with the mass of
earth would barely be larger than a coin
this makes them very hard to find so we
haven't actually observed any yet
if they exist they may even be the
mysterious dark matter
that holds galaxies together let's move
on to the kinds of black holes that we
know for sure
are out there stellar black holes
to make a black hole we need to compress
enough matter so that it collapses into
itself after that
the more mass we throw at it the larger
it becomes
in today's universe only the most
violent cosmic events can create the
necessary conditions
such as the merger of neutron stars or
when the core of a very massive star
collapses in a supernova
to have a unit to work with here we'll
use the mass of our sun
about 2 million trillion trillion
kilograms
the smallest known black hole has 2.7
times the mass of the sun
which works out as a sphere around 16
kilometers in diameter
large enough to cover paris another
lightweight black hole is the companion
to the v723
mon red giant star this star is 24 times
larger than our sun
30 million kilometers in diameter and
yet
it's thrown around by a tiny black hole
just 17.2 kilometers wide
this tiny thing bullying the star is so
much smaller that we can barely even
show them in comparison
one of the largest known stellar black
holes is m33x7
it currently spends its time eating a 70
solar mass blue giant
bit by bit as all that stolen matter
circles towards the black hole
like water going down a drain friction
heats it up to temperatures high enough
to shine
500 000 times brighter than our sun
and yet x7 is only 15.65 solar masses
and 92 kilometers wide just big enough
to cast a shadow on corsica
to grow much larger black holes have to
either devour a lot of stars
or better merge with one another the
instruments that make it possible to
detect
these mergers are very new so we're
currently discovering a lot of exciting
things
like two massive black holes that we
detected in a galaxy 17 billion light
years away
as they spun around each other violently
they released more
energy in the form of gravitational
waves than the combined light from all
the stars in the milky way
in 4400 years the new black hole they
formed
is about the size of germany and is 142
solar
masses and here we hit a curious
gap in scale there are lots of black
holes
up to 150 solar masses and then
there's nothing for a long time until we
suddenly hit black holes that are
millions of times more massive
which is a bit confusing because we had
this idea that black holes are
consistently growing and growing
but for the most massive black holes
this process is not fast enough to
explain their existence today
the universe is simply not old enough
for these supermassive black holes to
have formed by eating stars
and merging with each other something
else must have happened
to explain how we got the largest black
holes in the universe
we might need the largest stars that
ever existed
quasi-stars to get a sense of scale we
can compare them to the largest stars
that exist today
our sun is like a grain of sand next to
them
we don't know if quasi stars actually
existed
but they're an interesting concept when
it comes to supercharging black hole
development
the idea is that the matter in the early
universe was so dense
that quasi-stars could grow to thousands
of times the mass of our sun
the cores of these stars might have been
crushed by their own weight
so much to actually collapse into black
holes while the star was still forming
in contrast to stars today that would
destroy themselves in the process
inside stars a deadly balance could
emerge
gravity pressed the supermassive star
together feeding the black hole
and heating the material falling in to
such a degree that the radiation
pressure kept the star stable
and so these quickly growing black holes
might have been able to consume the
quasi-star for millions of years
and grow far bigger than any modern
stellar black hole
black holes several thousand times the
mass of the sun
and wider than the entire earth these
black holes might have become the seeds
for
supermassive black holes so now
we arrive at the kings of our universe
the largest
single bodies in existence the centers
of most galaxies contain a supermassive
black hole
and they are monstrous in the milky way
we have sagittarius a-star a
supermassive black hole with about four
million solar masses that is calm
and collected and just does its thing we
know
it sits there because we can see a
number of stars being thrown around by a
seemingly empty spot
and despite its incredible mess its
radius is still
only 17 times our sun smaller than most
giant stars
but millions of times more massive
because supermassive black holes are so
massive and located at the center of
galaxies
many people imagine them as being a bit
like the sun in the solar system
an anchor that glues everything else
together and forces it
into an orbit but this is a
misconception
while the sun makes up 99.86 percent of
all the mass
in the solar system supermassive black
holes usually only have
0.001 percent of the mass of their
galaxy
the billions of stars in galaxies are
not gravitationally bound to them
instead it's the gravitational effect of
dark matter which holds them together
many supermassive black holes aren't
gentle giants
especially when they're feeding on the
clouds of mass in their galaxy
the one at the center of the bl lucerti
galaxy is devouring so much material
that it produces jets of plasma
accelerated to nearly the speed of light
if earth were orbiting this huge body it
would seem 115 times larger than our sun
in the sky
and we'd be burnt to a crisp in seconds
by its glowing hot accretion disk
at this point black holes become so
large that stars
seem ridiculously tiny compared to them
the galaxy cygnus a has a supermassive
black hole with 2.5 billion
solar masses and 14.7 billion kilometers
wide
which would mean that if it took the
place of our sun it would swallow all
the planets
and stretch halfway to the edge of our
solar system
it's devouring so much mass and material
that it turns its disk into a kind of
magnetic funnel
spewing gas out making tremendous radio
lobes
towering over the galaxy half a million
light years in diameter
that's two and a half milky ways wide
another pretty large supermassive black
hole sits in the galaxy
messier 87 it has 6.5 billion solar
masses and was the first black hole we
got an actual photo of
or rather of the glowing gas around the
edge of a menacing shadow
this sphere of darkness is so large that
it covers our entire solar system
and yet there is a scale even above
these kinds of objects
ultramassive black holes
now we reach the most massive black
holes perhaps the largest single bodies
that will ever exist
these black holes have eaten so much
that they've grown to tens of billions
of solar masses
their gravity the engine for a quasar an
accretion disk
shining brighter than thousands of
galaxies full of stars
so massive that they deserve a title of
their own
ultra massive black holes the ultra
massive black hole at the center of
galaxy oj287
is 18 billion solar masses it's so big
that it has a supermassive black hole
nearly 40 times larger than sagittarius
a-star
orbiting it this thing defies
imagination
and is really hard to compare to
anything it can comfortably fit three
solar systems
side by side inside of it let's end
this insane competition and get to the
king of kings
ton 618 a black hole that we can observe
consuming galaxies worth of matter is
shining with the brightness of a hundred
trillion stars visible from 18 billion
light years away
it has an incredible 66 billion solar
masses
a black hole so large that it would take
light a week to reach the singularity
after crossing the event horizon about
11 solar systems could sit inside of it
side by side it may very well be the
largest
single body in the universe but in
reality it's probably even larger
since tun 618 is so far away we only see
what it looked like
10 billion years ago in any case
black holes are scary and mysterious
and gigantic they'll be here after
everything else dies
and growing larger and larger okay
now let's do the trip again from the
smallest possible black hole
all the way up to the largest
[Music]
let's try something new today we can
call this behind the lies
a short behind-the-scenes bit about the
necessary inaccuracies in this video
because it's not really actually
possible to rank black holes like
trading cards how so well while we've
cataloged millions of stars
we really only have good data on a
couple of dozen black holes
that's because black hole gazing wasn't
really a thing until 50 years ago
and technically still isn't because we
can't see black holes
we can only derive their properties from
studying their gravitational effects on
the matter around them
like the orbit of stars that come close
to them this effect depends on the mass
of the black hole which we can
approximate at the most basic level with
kepler's laws
but this comes with huge uncertainties
and error bars
then we have to convert mass to size
next which brings new uncertainties
for example we calculated the radius
from the mass using the schwarzschild
equation which for the sake of
simplicity
assumes black holes are perfectly round
and don't spin
a kind of black hole that doesn't really
exist the reality is that physics on
these scales
is a bit fuzzy so some of the black
holes we talked about here may be way
smaller
or way bigger we just don't know for
sure we shimmered around this problem by
comparing different sources with
different kinds of values
and using different mass calculations to
arrive at a standardized list that
allowed us to be as accurate as humanly
possible
you can look at all of this in our
source doc as a result this script was
written with the tears of experts we
drove
crazy with our obsession for the best
values they could live with
in this process tons of stuff got cut
and didn't make it into the final video
but luckily we found a way to not waste
all of it
we've created a lot of black hole merch
spanning the whole range from somewhat
bonkers to more serious
this way we get to explore a topic from
different angles and you get to continue
having fun with black holes
after this video ends
[Music]
you